citizens of the reject nation greg here
today
today i'm going to share with you all my
10 most unpopular movie opinions the
only way i can describe this list is by
the films i get the most crap for when i
admit that i actually like them or that
i don't actually like them so that is
what my ranking is comprised of so no to
get this out of the way i'm not gonna
try to convince anyone of my opinion not
gonna come close to trying whatever you
wanna argue with me about in the
comments i've already heard it in person
a gazillion times trust me so go ahead
leave it in the comments helps out with
the engagement of the video the films
down here that like i don't really care
for or that i don't like i can
objectively see why people really enjoy
these films a lot of this is mainly
coming from just a purely emotional
subjective state of viewing experience
is where i'm really coming from there's
a couple here though where i'm like i
don't understand yeah for all you guys
who are always like yeah that great guy
he's he's he's too mainstream and that's
why i can't trust his opinions well now
i'm gonna have this video just ready
ready to share that that one or two
comments or if you already didn't trust
my opinion then this will only help to
serve you and if you did trust my
opinion and now i'll have you question
my opinion hopefully that's the goal of
today's video is to question my whole
character anyway guys now let's just
have some fun leave a like kind of wish
the dislike button was still visible for
videos like this just be a really
amusing effect to mental health thinking
it'd be funny at first but then i die
slowly on the inside
[Music]
all right guys number ten i love that
i'm kicking it off with this one this
movie actually has a pretty decent
critic score on rotten tomatoes but once
i say you're gonna know for sure like oh
yeah yeah the audiences don't like this
movie i actually had a really fun time
when i saw it and that is ghostbusters
2016. go ahead type away tell me
everything you don't like about it i
don't care when i watched this film i
actually had a really great time i
thought it was funny i thought the main
ensemble doesn't compare to the original
ensemble like this movie in total does
not compare to the original but in terms
of a remake in terms of a comedy i would
say that this is just fine that it is a
good time when i saw it i was laughing i
enjoyed the action i like chris
hemsworth a lot in the film does it have
that problem that a lot of judd apatow
films have where it's like oh he really
let the actors just improvise a lot and
then they put it together in the editing
room i understand that's paul feig not
joe at the time judd comparison yeah it
does have that issue but the end product
for me as someone who has a major
affinity for the first two ghostbusters
films i would say that i actually really
enjoyed this one quite a bit we're off
to a strong start people let's go on at
number nine number nine a movie that
might seem weird to put on here at first
because it's actually a best picture
winner and by me saying that you might
actually go oh i think i know where
greg's going with this yeah i mean i
only saw it one time i saw it in the
theaters and i was quite moved by it i
was moved to tears several times and
that is the best picture winner crash
the movie that whenever people talk
about best picture winners they're like
what that movie would white what crazy
crush sucks i get it you know even when
i was younger i saw this one was like 14
years old when i saw it in the theaters
at that age even i had moments of kind
of feeling like there's an adult talking
at me instead of letting the characters
do real talking but i can't deny i think
the movie's emotion really clicked with
me i was very much movement i think the
performances are very strong you know
what on a very personal note i saw this
when i was 14 years old i'm gonna get
real pretty real with you guys right now
you know even though i grew up of course
knowing racism is wrong even like in the
school i had all my friends we had like
a tight-knit group of like 30 kids and
it was a diverse group of kids however i
was still surrounded by like a lot of
adults even some kids who had some
thoughts that could only be deemed as
prejudice like they were some prejudice
thoughts and when you're that young a
lot of time you don't even realize that
you're having thoughts that are
insensitive or that actually would be
qualified as prejudice and there's a
scene in this movie and it's always
stuck with me and that is when sandra
bullock is having the locks change she's
arguing with brendan fraser and she's
talking about the guy changing their
locks these gang bangers gonna be giving
the key out to his gangbanger friends
he's just profiling this guy and being
completely racist based off of the way
he looks and at the time of seeing that
scene it made me cringe because i knew
people who thought that way and it made
me realize at 14 not thirty year old
crap fourteen you know actually that
those thoughts and fears and tension in
my shoulders does come into mind
whenever i see someone who happens to
fit that description of what she's
talking about and from that moment on
from that movie it made me go i'm not
going to think like that anymore
and then greg cured all of racism crash
saved racism that stopped it the movie
did its goal and now no more racism all
right number eight a classic a classic
film
i think it's fine all right i don't
dislike it i i think it's
i think it's very very fine
that's like the best i can go with it
it's one of those movies where i can
watch it and go yes
i understand why you love it not for me
so much though raiders of the lost ark i
think out of the original trilogy of
indiana jones films it is the only one
that i watch where i actually tune out
pretty much through a lot of it when i
am watching it are there things that i
appreciate about the film undoubtedly i
do think harrison ford does a good job i
do like uh karen allen i think some of
the the practical effects the rolling
ball at the beginning yeah it's all fun
and exciting uh sure for the most part
though uh i don't find a lot of the plot
that entertaining i don't find the
characters even though the performances
are good i don't find the characters
that intriguing i find the mystery the
puzzle solving a little dull the action
is just kind of okay to me for for most
of the film yeah it's just fine it's the
best i got for it i'd much rather watch
temple to do all right i'm gonna put
number seven and six together just kind
of decided right now because i i'm
pretty sure i got like the same opinion
about both these films these are two
classic horror movies that kick-started
some of the biggest horror franchises of
all time i find them extremely overrated
especially one of them that i often see
as one of the greatest horror films of
all time the only way i can describe
this to you is uh um i i'm bored out of
my [ __ ] mind when i watch these films
that is halloween and friday the 13th
i've seen both these movies countless
times i've tried i've really tried to
get on board with them and i just can't
do it maybe it's my inability to
transplant my body and soul into the
time period when this was released
before better versions of these movies
came out maybe that's debatable too like
no those are the best i don't think
they're the best i think that they are
slow meandering the characters very
uninteresting i don't think they're
scary i don't think they're thrilling i
don't think they're uh schlockly amusing
i i just find them really really dull
experiences i kind of like the finales
of both of them i kind of like them but
for the most part i always walk away
going i think that's very overrated and
i'm not gonna share this opinion with
the group that i'm with and if i'm being
really honest with you from being very
real with y'all i think the halloween
2018 movie far surpasses the original
and if i'm gonna be really really really
really honest
i think the halloween rob zombie version
is way more enjoyable
the theatrical cut i'm not a big fan of
the director's cup and number five here
we go now i actually referenced this
movie when i was talking about the
batman the few qualities that i can say
i i i like i appreciate i would say the
qualities of this movie that i saw
reflected in the batman was what made me
happy but the actual movie itself that i
referenced i don't understand why people
my entire life have said it's one of the
greatest screenplays of all time i've
heard many filmmakers tours say that
this is the best script ever written
often hailed as one of the best movies
of all time and every time i watch it i
always have to divide up my viewing
experience i can never finish this in
one sitting i even tried before the
batman to watch this in one sitting but
i can't do it i start to snooze i start
to think of different things i'm not
even on my phone i'm not one of those
guys when watching a movie who's on his
phone it's the movie chinatown like i
said i'm not gonna convince anyone of
why this movie is a snooze fest but yeah
i i am bored as hell whenever i watch it
and i think if more people were honest
with themselves they'd admit that too
all right number four this is the one i
think i have never been shy to admit of
how much i really liked this film like
i'm willing to die on this hill and i
know i'm
vastly in the minority the star of this
movie pretty much disavows it it kind of
i kind of got the impression that
everyone involved tries to like
screw that movie genuinely considered
like a really terrible film and won a
razzy for being so bad but whenever i
watch it i do not share that sentiment
it is not nostalgia i think we watched
it as an adult like a couple years ago
and i still went
i don't understand i just it's one of
those i i just don't understand i don't
understand why
why i'm one of the few people who has
this opinion i think it's a good movie
wild wild west i think it's really funny
i love the chemistry with will smith and
kevin kline i think it's very inventive
i think it's a very creative movie kind
of is a little bit clunky in the
beginning a lot of people say it's
clunky throughout but i think in the
beginning it's a little bit clunky but
as it progresses the time you get those
two teamed up i think it's funny zany i
love some of the action scenes a lot
gadgets are really cool and again the
chemistry between those two i would like
more sci-fi westerns like this that have
just kind of a tongue-in-cheek aspect to
it so yeah i'd say wild wildsmith is an
actual good movie
in this guy's opinion let's say
wildsmithing said wow wild smith i
apologize number three here we go star
wars fans listen up i'm willing to
reignite this debate you thought this
debate was over no no no let's get it
going for another 10 more years
i think the last jedi is the best out of
the disney trilogy now even though in
real life it has not been the most
shocking reaction from people for me to
say that undoubtedly this is the movie
i've had the most arguments with people
about arguments i never want to get into
and then it becomes one i'm like oh crap
here i am
i guess i'm arguing and that's the last
jedi i'm only gonna go over a couple of
things here i think ryan johnson gets a
lot of crap for this movie as you all
know i agree the poe dameron side of it
not that interesting the fin side of it
very dull the rey and luke skywalker and
the kylo ren stuff for most of that i
actually really really enjoy it and the
luke skywalker portrayal here makes
sense now when i first saw this movie i
said i loved it and i did i meant it
when i rewatched it when i watched the
films in release date order leading up
to the rise of skywalker it actually
went down a couple like quite a bit i
was like oh you know maybe i don't love
this movie i like it though i still like
it a lot but i i don't love it the luke
skywalker thing is something i just i i
can't seem to agree with people on like
i can i can understand i can actually
understand but when i watch this film
i'm like well ryan johnson didn't do the
setup with the force awakens like they
had the first order now in power kylo
ren established as a guy who fell to the
dark side who was the nephew of luke
skywalker and was also a student of luke
skywalker so with the time you get to
luke skywalker makes sense why he would
be the guy that he is this dude who is
so resistant towards everything that it
means to be a jedi i love the arc that
he has in that film and he gets a lot of
[ __ ] for that one moment where he whips
out his lightsaber for i believe 0.5
seconds because he was tempted but when
i watch this movie i'm like he's human
he's a skywalker he's the son of darth
vader it's perfectly human to me that he
would have a moment where he's kind of
tempted by i've seen some darkness that
may be oh maybe i should like do
something to remove it like i actually
don't blame him for that moment like i
said i have heard it all a billion times
when i watch it i understand the
portrayal i understood what ryan johnson
was going for is it the best star wars
film not by a long shot but out of the
disney trilogy i actually feel like it's
more than just nostalgia bait i really
like some of the things that it was bold
enough to actually explore and i like
the art that luke skywalker has boom i
said it
number two
is a movie that i should love i should
love this film this movie was designed
for me i'm gonna tell you what it is
right now
heat it took me must have been my 20th
time maybe watching this movie to
realize i have my whole life been
trying to convince myself that i
actually like this movie but i've been
lying to myself this whole time i don't
really think i like this movie slow burn
crime dramas crime action films that's
like my main jam i know we mainly talk
about like comic books big ip's here but
that's actually my main jam when it
comes to genre films also de niro pacino
massive de niro pacino fans especially
when i started watching this film when i
was younger i would literally create my
own little cinematic universe what i
would do is that alternate it'd be
pacino film de niro pacino de niro
pacino de niro i'd watched their
individual films and then i would watch
heat the culmination film of 30 years of
waiting for these guys to come together
and yeah whenever i admit this to
someone oh boy that reaction is not
pleasant i like the first 15 minutes of
this film a lot like the opening heist
it feels like oh yeah the dark knight
definitely borrowed some tonality from
it i like the first 15 minutes 20
minutes maybe i think de niro from
beginning to end is excellent the last
half hour can get on board with that
first scene when they do have their like
the coffee shop scene together where
they do meet i enjoy that great acting
final heist great a lot about the finale
i enjoy and a lot about the beginning
but keep in mind it's a three hour movie
so most of this movie i do find i don't
give a [ __ ] about the characters a
little bit meandering a lot of mellow
drama that just does not click for me
and really loses the drive of this film
i think everyone's doing a good job like
in terms of acting for the most most
people i think are doing a good job yet
the writing i just don't enjoy the
storytelling of most of these people it
just plays like a soap opera to me so
much of the time instead of a
hard-hitting drama i'm just like god
damn this is taking [ __ ] forever
every time i watch it i just try to like
it but i had to be honest with myself
last time watch it like i don't really
like this movie even though everyone
does a good job he's still one of my
favorite actors of all time but god damn
i i think al pacino's over-the-topness
in this film is just so
obnoxious and annoying
great ass
like every time i watch i'm like there's
there's no way this guy's a cop like
there's no way
this guy
is a cop i don't see it it's the
furthest thing from believable and it's
just way too over the top for me even
though i like the scenes he has with the
nero those very few ones for most part i
find his performance just incredibly
distracting and yeah i get it believe me
i do i've listened to a lot of think
pieces about this film that
adore this movie yeah no but that's the
point of the film that's it's not just a
straightforward action thriller it's
about diving into the intimate lives
like yeah the dinner pacino they're the
best at what they do but man their
personal lives are [ __ ] up and
everyone around them their lives are
really harsh too yeah all that stuff not
saying i couldn't do without it i just
think the execution of it does not click
with me and uh i i think it could have
been shorter and could have been written
better because i'm just not moved by
vast majority of it all right guys
number one
number one number one shouldn't be
number one the reason it's number one is
because more than what i said about heat
the second i say
when i'm about to state right now for
you easily leads into whoever i'm saying
this to climbing down my throat
every single time you know what it makes
me think of it makes me think of that
family guy moment when peter admits i
did not care for the godfather what like
i like this movie i do i actually like
this room that's why i don't think it
should be number one but no movie on
this list warrants
the same reaction i tend to get out of
anyone i say this to here it is
i think captain america winter soldier
is a little overrated and that's usually
how i present it i just say it's a
little overrated some people are like
the greatest action of all time like you
had some of the best action out of the
mcu but is it really some of the best
action of all time like i think of a
bunch of movies that have just way
better action i like the action like
especially for an mcu film i do it's
good i think it's a solid plot political
thriller when i'm watching it i wouldn't
say i'm bored my main thing is is people
are constantly hailing this movie as the
best mcu movie to have ever existed i
constantly hear it or number two but a
lot of time it's number one i think i
liked it more the first time i stopped
whenever i've re-watched it at home it's
the same feeling while i enjoy it while
i think it's a good plot
i don't really care about the characters
in this movie i never really had an
attachment to bucky leaning into this i
kind of cared about bucky more in civil
war actually they care about bucky a lot
more in civil war captain america
natasha well good performers just very
straightforward and i'm i'm not that
engaged into whatever emotional journeys
they're going on in this film like when
i think about this movie even though
i've seen it several times i do kind of
just flash to some of the action scenes
but like character moments or whatever
they don't really land a punch for me
like good plot twist the first time you
watched it i just don't get hit with
that feeling of this is the most
brilliant thing out of the marvel
cinematic universe the number one
reaction i get is people constantly are
telling me you're wrong you're wrong
you're wrong
i don't even like really try just like
i'm just telling you for some reason
just doesn't fly with me for that that
strong i like it i do think it's a
little overrated but it's just not to me
one of the top three favorites even from
from the mcu anyway guys well those are
uh easily my 10 most unpopular opinions
what are your most unpopular movie
opinions what's the ones you get the
most crap for for either liking or
disliking leave it down in the comments
below
thank you for engaging with me see you
soon citizens